[Music]
whether caring for parents
grandparents or partners as they age how
best to help the elderly and those with
dementia
is a question that affects everyone if i
hug her
she pushes me away because i'm a
stranger you know
around the world people are living
longer but many governments spend very
little
on long-term care for the elderly
and covid19 has brought things to crisis
point
more deaths in care homes than in
hospitals the care assistants have moved
in
so they can keep the virus out one in
four residents here now
dead the pandemic has sort of
highlighted
everything that is wrong with
institutional care
across the rich world around half of
covert 19
deaths have been in care homes despite
the fact
just under one percent of people live in
them
but the pandemic also offers a unique
opportunity to rethink care
and the devastation caused by covert 19
could be a tipping point
in how societies treat their old people
what do you find challenging it's not
remembering things isn't it
oh it's not following conversations um
things like forgetfulness you'll see
you're not projecting so
here and there the challenges of caring
for people as they age
will affect everyone because you didn't
have that on problems
if not now then soon there's something
wrong
share of people over 80 is expected to
double
in the next 30 years and at the same
time
there will be fewer people of working
age to look after the elderly especially
in the rich world
take spain for every 10 working age
people in the country today
there are currently three people over
retirement age
by 2050 there will be eight
close to a one to one ratio
we are tipping into sort of being 65
plus
societies there is a simple question of
who is going to look after
these people in a dignified way
the cost of care is a major factor in
these decisions
in america alone almost half of those
who reach the age of 65 will need some
form of paid care
and as these costs are highest in rich
countries one solution could be to
outsource
care internationally
this is ban kamlang chai in northern
thailand
it's home to 14 residents from germany
in switzerland
[Music]
maya is the youngest resident at 60.
she was diagnosed with dementia 10 years
ago
i said to her you know i promise you
maya i
i will do always the best you don't have
to worry i promise you that
the care system in much of europe means
it's often family members who take on
the burden of care
and maya came to thailand when her
husband walter could no longer look
after her
i realized if i carry on with this
i will die before maya i will i will be
flat in in a few months and the children
told me also
you better do something now because you
cannot do
both work and taking care of your wife
[Music]
all the residents here have dementia and
across the world
it's thought between a third and a half
of those 85 or older
have the condition there is no cure
and the global cost of dementia by 2030
will be a staggering
2 trillion dollars every year
residents with dementia here have three
carers each
providing around the clock care for a
fraction of the equivalent cost in
switzerland
but not everyone approves of sending
loved ones to the other side of the
world
well i got a letter from a school friend
of my wife
she tell me i'm a big idiot uh disposing
my wife in thailand and i'm stingy
the best thing we could have done
this shortage of stuff like everywhere
in europe
in these care homes nobody has time to
really look after her
she deserves better than just put in a
corner and look at the wall
the center was founded by swiss
entrepreneur martin woodley
after his own mother was diagnosed with
dementia
are you hungry a bit
a little bit okay and let's go
it's one of several care centers in
northern thailand that market their
services to europeans
here in our village what we try to do
we try to to make the atmosphere like
just
normal life in a village
communicate motherhood i would
wish that it would be possible much more
going back to the family
much more going back to the community
system and
solves the problem in that way what are
you doing
you're buying chocolate
but few communities in the west can
provide this type of one-on-one care
and personalized nursing like this is
only available to the very richest
people
[Music]
so some care providers are looking for
other ways to keep people at home
and in their communities for longer
thousands of miles away in southern
england
afsal and his wife zora are part of a
pilot scheme to help dementia sufferers
live longer and healthier lives
at home your turn
i think he would only be ready to go
into a care home
if he was so bad he wouldn't even know
he was going to care home
i hope it never comes
[Music]
in much of the rich world a significant
portion of long-term care
is provided in care homes but the
practice of caring for people in large
institutions as they age has been called
into question by the pandemic
which left many care home residents cut
off from family
and its increased risk of disease
across the rich world around half of all
covert 19
deaths occurred in care homes and in
canada and australia
the estimated figure is closer to 80
percent
we have institutionalized care but both
covered
as well as just the fact that life is
much longer than we ever thought it
would be
mean that experts are starting to
question whether that is really the best
way
to deliver care many experts now believe
around
half of the care provided in care homes
could be done at home
technology can help
afzal has dementia and there are sensors
fitted around his home to track his
movements
the data gathered by the sensors are fed
back to a remote monitoring team
along with medical readings like afsa's
blood pressure
and temperature i've never seen that red
light before
retry what's happening
it means there's somebody watching all
the time that's very reassuring
the monitoring team would then know that
the patient is eating
is drinking is looking after themselves
all the carers looking after them
when i do some cooking or something i
leave the fire on
just my head
the support of the remote monitoring
team helps relieve
some of the pressures on unpaid carers
like zora
and save money for overstretched health
systems looks like it's come up to about
90 and then drop down again
it looks like they repeated it and it
came back as normal real-time data from
afsa's home is collected here
and if they notice changes to
temperature or blood pressure that might
indicate infection
they're able to intervene early and
prevent costly hospital admissions
one in four hospital beds are currently
being occupied with people with dementia
and because the current service can't
cope with the increasing number
and the resources that require we need
to bring a new model of working
so with this model with treat formatters
we were able to monitor 500 people
something that is impossible to do in a
normal
outpatient appointment
[Music]
but while technology like this can
reduce the ratio of carers to patients
it can't fully tackle the fundamental
problem
there simply are not enough people to
look after the elderly
there are shortages of carers everywhere
and why might that be well number of
reasons one we don't
look after carers very well at all
so pay is one of the most obvious things
in britain
social carers tend to be paid less than
people who work in supermarkets
the demand on people who work on it the
stress levels the injury levels etc
are just very very high if you add those
two things up you might think well there
are easier ways to
to make your money in germany
a third of care workers leave their job
after a year
and in most rich countries a care home
worker is paid
36 less than someone doing a similar job
in a hospital
[Music]
changing the way the elderly are cared
for will require profound
political and structural upheaval
but it's just possible the pandemic
could provide the necessary momentum
it's never going to win you an election
and so politicians walk
pass the potato on and on and on and on
and on and maybe covered will be that
moment
maybe covered will be that moment where
you just can't ignore it any longer i
certainly hope so
i'm sachin alter public policy editor at
the economist
this film was inspired by a piece that i
wrote about how
covered 19 was highlighting the flaws of
elderly care
to read it please click on this link
thanks for watching
and don't forget to subscribe